Allah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
In one of the
verses towards the middle of Alan, he
says, "And hold all of you to the rope
of Allah together and do not become
divided." This verse is known to many of
us.
The rope of Allah here, what is intended
by it? When you look at what the
companions
the explanation they gave or the
definition that they gave for the rope
of Allah, they are many. Some will
mention the rope of Allah is Islam.
Others mention the rope of Allah is the
Quran.
sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam etc.
But we notice that all of these
definitions
are descriptions of a different angle of
the same thing. Right? So for instance,
Islam hold all of you to Islam and do
not become divided and hold all of you
to the Quran and hold all of you to the
sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. They all mean or entail or
arrive at the same conclusion. And the
prophet sallallam
said,
he said, "The rope of Allah
is the book of Allah which extends from
the heavens to the earth.
Now we notice here in the wording of
this verse that Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
stresses togetherness
and he stresses anything that will
put that togetherness at at risk. So
he says subhanahu wa ta'ala and hold all
of you to the rope of Allah together.
That's the first part. The second he
says and do not become divided.
So we understand from this that
not it is not enough for a person to
hold to the rope of Allah alone.
This person has not fulfilled
his duty as a Muslim. And now we kind of
live in that kind of time, don't we? The
mega city, right? the anonymity of just
minding your own business. As long as
you're out there not hurting anybody,
right? We see someone doing something
wrong or making a mistake, we don't
correct him. We see someone going to
harm himself or others, we don't correct
them. This kind of anonymity and tap
this is the practice of a people whose
Islam is not complete. It is the
practice of a people whose iman is not
fulfilled. Notice something.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has made it
that no prayer will be valid unless you
recite fat. Correct? No prayer. You have
to recite in every prayer and in every
of every prayer too.
But when we pray, if we were to really
follow the prophet's sunnah completely
and in practice, in practice, do we pray
most of the time alone or together? Most
of the time. Most of the time in
practice, we pray alone. Right?
However, in spite of that,
we still say
even though you're praying alone, you
still say we
you alone do we worship.
You would think that if you're praying
alone, you would say you alone, oh
Allah, I worship, right? Or even if the
imam is reciting on behalf of the people
he's leading, he could still say you
alone do I worship and they say am
behind him. But it is phrased
you alone do we worship. even if you're
praying alone. Why? The scholars tell us
that there is a very important point and
that is that a person who worships Allah
alone
constantly and does not put his hand in
the hands of his Muslim brothers and
sisters. for better or worse
in difficulty and in ease this person
his Islam is incomplete
right his Islam is incomplete because
when you say you alone do I worship your
humility isn't isn't as far as it should
be there is much more humility in the
anonymity of we worship you alone alone
do we wor who am I to put myself as you
alone do I worship no I worship amongst
those who worship and this is why Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala commands
he says and establish prayer and give
zak and
bow down with those who are bowing
down. He already mentioned prayer.
What's meant is a person must be with
and together.
And the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam stressed this so much that even
in our physical behavior,
anything that would jeopardize that
togetherness is strictly forbidden in
Islam. So for instance, you look at the
emphasis that Allah that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam put on
straightening the rose.
He said
he said
he said Sallallah.aii wasallam.
Straighten your rows. Make them as
straight as possible. And do not differ
with one another in the row. Do not
differ with one another in your stance
in the row. This one is slightly
forward. This one's slightly behind.
This one is slightly far apart. These
two are very that inconsistency.
This is prohibited. And not only that,
but it's punishable. It comes at a
price. When we differ with one another,
even in the row in salah, it comes at a
price. What is the price? He said,
"Sallam,
if you differ with one another in your
stance in the row and the row is hence
incoherent or crooked, then your hearts
will become different. they will differ.
The scholars derive from this statement
that if your bodies differ
that will lead to the differing of the
hearts.
If the body differs with the other body
that will lead to differing of the
hearts.
Right?
So
if a person stands in the row and is out
of place in the row and this continues
over time,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala may punish
that people with difference in their
opinions, in their hearts, in their
obedience, in their adherence. They will
start to differ with each other.
And for this reason,
even outside of salah, it's not
permissible to differ in that way. And
Muslim, the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam was on a journey with the
companions
and he stopped to make camp one night.
And when he stopped, the people spread
out. You know how people spread out to
set up their respective camps. Each one
has his tent and so forth. And they were
in a valley. And so they spread out more
than they usually were. And so the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam said to
them,
he says, "It is a who has caused you all
to spread out this far from each other.
Come in closer. They're going to go to
sleep. They're going to sleep and make
their campfire and make their soup or
make their bread or whatever they're
going to do. They're not praying.
They're not in salah. But he said is the
one who has spread you out even while
you're sleeping, even while you're
camping. not permissible
because of the danger of that differing
whether it's in salah whether it's in
the way that we live with each other
whether it's in the way all of these
things may jeopardize that togetherness
and with disagreement
and differing what comes differing in
religion
what does that mean meaning that let's
Say two people have a disagreement, a
personal issue,
and as they spread from each other and
as they differ more and more, they will
start to want to get people on their
side for their difference of opinion.
And what better way to get people on
your side than to spiritualize your
endeavor, right? To make it that, oh,
this isn't a personal issue. It's
because of Allah. It's because this is
haram. It's because and from that comes
all of the different groups and sex and
innovation that are introduced. It
usually roots back to people differing
on a personal level. So this is
something that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam stressed so much that even if
this occurs in the Quran we are to end
the gathering. He said
Muslim we'll end with this. He said
he said
recite the Quran together as long as you
are in agreement with each other. But if
you start to differ then stop.
So that differing even if it is over
what? Even if it is over or in a
gathering of the recitation of the Quran
that is not what the Quran was revealed
for. The Quran was revealed
that disagreement is it a related
or a dean related
[Arabic recitation]
any disagreement dunya or deen. And
that's the point that we're making is
that most disagreements are based on
what the dunya but then when they extend
what do they turn into? They morph into
a dean issue
because people attempt to spiritualize
their their their fights and their
endeavors. It's human nature. Now, so he
tells us sallallah.aii wasallam recite
the Quran as long as you are in
agreement but if you start to differ
then
stop and and end the gathering. Why?
Because the Quran was not revealed for
that. And this is regarding what? the
differing of the different recitations.
Which is why
one of his biggest
and the most landmark of his
achievements was that in his he united
the ummah on one recitation which is the
recitation the one that we have today
which is it's referred to as
do you want to say something I'm not
going to point at you some people see
this as root
But you got different kinds of point.
You got this one. You got this one. You
got the military point. And then you've
got the Bill Clinton point. So I'm going
to give you the bill one. Go ahead.
[Arabic recitation]
Every single one of us as an individual,
as a Muslim, so we don't differ. So we
don't
[Arabic recitation]
do? What is the solution? The solution
is is it is categorically impermissible
to remove yourself from the jama of the
Muslims.
Especially when there's differing
people differ, they start to I'm not
going in there anymore. I'm not talking
to this guy anymore. I'm not doing this
anymore. That is where the beginning of
the end starts. Right? So we are forced
to work out our differences at all
times. Now
Alhamdulillah.